c'est un immense défi que la nasa a
confié la sonde osiris rex lancée en
2016 rapporté l'équivalent d'au moins
une cuillère à soupe de pierres et de
poussières provenant de l'astéroïde
bennoo qui se trouve à plus de 300
millions de km de la terre
une cargaison précieuse non contaminée
qui pourrait éclairer certain mystère
vieux de plusieurs milliards d'années
on va là pour découvrir nos origines ce
sac est fondamental on essaye de
comprendre comment la vie a pu
apparaître sur terre
osiris rex a mis 2 ans a rejoint de
bennoo dont la taille est semblable à
celle de l' empire state building un
appareil conçu par l' agence spatiale
canadienne l'a ensuite patiemment
cartographier avec un grand luxe de
détails le corps célestes lemieux
cartographie du système solaire on a
pris 3 milliards de la nasa espère
identifier une surface large et dégagé
sur l'astéroïde afin de permettre à la
sonde de prélever son échantillon de sol
sans trop de risques mais voici ce qu'il
attendait le sol inégal accidenté
recouvert damas rochus on avait prévu le
mieux qu'on a réussi à trouver d'environ
10 rayons trois étages poésie à poser
une sonde grosse comme un minibus sur
l'équivalent d'une douzaine d espaces de
stationnement il a fallu plusieurs
heures d' approche à très faible vitesse
puis un bras télescopique s'est approché
du sol a libéré un gaz et aspirer les
roches il a poussé a soulevé par le jet
le
une quinzaine de secondes malgré le
succès de la manoeuvre il faudra
attendre quelques jours pour savoir la
quantité de sols prélevés par la sonde
correspond aux attentes de la nasa
toucherait la surface échantillons pour
pouvoir la tentative à trois c'est la
première fois depuis les missions apollo
de la nasa tentait de ramener un
échantillon de sol extraterrestre même
si la quantité minime pour des
chercheurs c'est une véritable aubaine
il suffit d'une petite quantité de
poussière de régolithe en fait cette
poussière qui est dessus de l'astéroïde
donc on est capable maintenant de faire
tout ce processus d' analyse même avec
une fraction du très très faible du
matériel qu'on récupère pour avoir
contribué à l'émission le canada a droit
à sa part du gâteau on va obtenir 4 % en
fait de la masse de l'échantillon alors
on souhaite qu' elle soit la plus grosse
possible si on a quatre passante de
kilos on sera tous bien content et ça
nous permettra vraiment de mener un tout
un tas de batteries d'expérience et ça
c'est formidable
si tout va bien aux eris rex une mission
qui a coûté 8,5 millions de da la
quittera bennoo en mars prochain avec
son trésor il déposera sur terre en 2023
is normand grondin radio canada montréal